thank you
[Music]
we're gonna end with a uh am I
yes I love these all right so what we
have here is there's a 25 year old woman
who lives with her husband she's
oh did I jump the gun she she lives with
her husband did but you're probably
right
and the four-year-old in their house
right that's not hers no it's nothing
like that okay 25 year old woman living
with her husband and a four-year-old and
the other extra bedroom lives her 20
year old sister and she's staying there
because the house is close to the
college so it's convenient sounds like
the beginning of a porn they let her
stay over is she fine though I think she
is and sometimes she walks out of the
room in like a big shirt and underwear
or Sports
um so the 25 year old woman has asked
her sister multiple times hey can you
cover up when you leave the room cause
I'm sure your tits everywhere but she's
saying it's a little inappropriate
because I don't want my four-year-old to
get the wrong impression of how to I
don't know carry themselves oh but she's
okay with the husband with the boner
that's the thing the 20 year old is
saying you're just mad because I'm
getting the attention of your husband
that's a weird thing to say yeah and now
you don't pay rent on the issue is she
she's asking if she's an [__] for
asking her sister to cover up around
no she paying rent yeah
I wonder what she looks yeah but there's
got to be like let's just say he's
[__] fine there's got to be common
dads shoes yeah you're an [__]
because she your sister's house
24 year old why are you [__] blocking
yeah dude she probably was right about
the husband though too because because
you know girls have a sense of like what
guys are doing and [__] like they know
they could see like oh yeah he's
probably checking me out and so she's
like you're mad because he's looking at
me like why would you just say that's a
crazy response to say to yourself even
know that is like really really weird
right so like let's let's um if she's
paying rent then that means they're
roommates when you have a roommate then
you already have to like come to certain
compromises regardless of the situation
so if there's an issue it's like you got
to be able to talk it out and if
somebody is compromised you know what I
mean that's like we gotta talk is the
husband's meat antenna like pointing at
the sister yeah it is so isn't it would
it like the husband and the son is just
staring at her every day I do think it's
weird for the older sister to be like
hey uh can you like cover up because
like I want my four-year-old to no dude
just say the [__] truth hey do you
mind like not being so hot in front of
my husband yeah she couldn't you know
what I'm saying if she said it like that
just keep it real with you like like
you're kind of looking too good in front
of my woman growing up with my sisters
and my mother walk I would walk around
the house in my underwear sometimes and
my my sisters would be like can you put
some [__] clothes on I'd be like no
really they want you to put clothes on
they'd be like dude stop walking around
your underwear and I was like oh okay
but siblings is different when this is a
like a romantic Partners in the house as
well though like can you put on some
clothes or too [__] around us
making this all hot yeah oh dude yeah
like like what if in your house tiffs
Tiff's had a sister that was banging and
she would just stay over and was staying
with you guys from stabbing himself
which would you like back up Tiff when
she's like she shouldn't be walking
around her underwear I think
um in common spaces I think that's
appropriate to ask you should be wearing
clothes I think you're doing it she's
wearing shoes are prude and what should
be done is you should go no I think all
of us should be naked oh except for that
kid except for the kid because that's
underage I think we're thinking with our
male heads right now you guys
I'm pretty sure I think I said it and
I'll be like hey hey hey wait what was
your take hey hey you're both sisters
that means same genetics so if I'm
married to you I'm married to you
[Applause]
yeah okay stops the whole argument yeah
what if what if in your house turkey
today is to have this conversation
ladies ladies ladies what if in your
house you and Tiff right yeah let's say
you have this like hot gorgeous model
brother that stays over and he's got
he's hella tall has really nice ears
[__] Yoshi
constantly shirtless always drinking
milk like out of the fridge right there
couldn't be blacker oh God damn it and
he's always walking around with his dick
out and he's way bigger than yours yeah
obviously in my life would you be like
what would you do would you say
something Rick yeah chill
yeah I would say something what if he's
like nah dude you're just jealous
I would try to beat his ass and then I
might lose but like I'll try to make a
competitive I know how you can make them
uncomfortable oh okay call me over when
he's doing that and I'll start jacking
off on in the living room that's good
that's probably because you gotta top it
you gotta top it like if he's being a
[__] rude boy
you gotta top it but I think I'm like
there's no four-year-old kid in this if
you if you're staying bro if you're
staying at someone's house like I think
you should try to be somewhat you know
on your best behavior okay so the
leverage in this situation should be in
favor of the asker I think we're I think
we're all the owner the owners set the
rules the wife yeah yeah like if if
she's asking you I think it's it's not
that big of an ask like what you can't
put on some sweats lady like what you
walk around your underwear like that's
that's kind of crazy like those
see-through t-shirts I and if you're if
your response is oh you're just jealous
because my husband's looking at me
I think that's because it's a retort to
her trying to make it about the
four-year-old yeah I think that's I
think that's a not appropriate approach
uh or not the best approach but it's
still [__] but it's also if it's she
don't got a kid what the [__] does she
know about having a baby you know like
like it does sound like there's some
unhealed [__] between the two sisters I
need to talk at that's weird [__] with
siblings dude
the sister was smoking hot right if the
sister was smoking hot and she was
coming out like in scantily clad close
but like let's say the husband made the
wife feel really secure like like you're
all I see I only love you I don't give a
[__] whatever but if the wife is still
speaking like that then it's just her
coming out of her own insecurity that's
something she kind of needs to work on
too then well what if it's really about
the kids and they just don't want the
kids to see that what if the kid starts
[__] like looking at Auntie and going
oh Auntie can I see your boobies yeah oh
damn and then she's like
why that's weird also though if at this
point if I think the line was crossed if
the youngest is like you're just mad
that like I got the attention your
husband that's when it's like okay so
even if you're right you got to leave
now yeah
get out like hey you you're right you
got it now it's it's weird they're doing
her a favor by letting her stay at their
place obviously paying rent right yeah
but to go to the college it's like you
be less disrespectful like that's crazy
you're a very 20 year old response yeah
and what if she's all like in your face
she wears like The Tick Tock
um
and then she walks around always
dropping DVDs and things she has to pick
back up she's a clumsy Gal A husband
you know she's dropping VHS just
dropping Blu-rays everywhere dude she
has a [__] bowl of marbles that she
accidentally spills and she has to keep
picking them up one by one while he's
trying to play his games yeah a couple
of the marbles drop on his pants yeah
I don't know I think uh maybe maybe her
family is just a bunch of [__] dude
it seems like it seems like everyone
tiptoes about stuff yeah and then they
just don't have good Community they're
just annoying do you believe when let's
say that this young girl who's like hot
and always is around this husband of her
sisters do you believe her when she says
she had no intention of even catching
his eye
uh I don't know who knows I have eyes
only for you I feel like most girls have
that default like I wasn't I'm just
being my like they have that default
idea but I think they [__] know yeah
maybe yeah I know who's looking because
I think most girls are actually more
this than this yeah that's true yeah
statistically yeah it would be more like
like if you're if you're if your lady
had a sister yeah and then like let's
say uh your lady went to work and you're
at home yeah she would probably Veer
more on the covered outside versus oh my
sister's gone yeah that's weird
I'm [__] breakfast I'll be like what
the [__] yeah yeah there's something
going on for sure also when when a girl
is more this than this yeah that's
already like The Uncommon yeah which
means they're aware of that right they
have to be aware dude like when you stay
you stay at your mother-in-law's place
right you're not walking around your
[__] underwear or Bart might yeah I'm
different that's true that's true but I
think they know about you right like
they know they're like oh yeah boy I run
into the street in just my underwear I
do that I do that too for an emergency
or what just just to get something out
of my car I also think for the girls are
like this just if a girl's like yeah I
don't even know what this is but it's
just not this if a girl is conscious
that she's this type of girl I also
think that if guys are caught slipping
or not paying attention it's not those
guys's fault
well yeah that's like a [__] it's
like a fly you know what I mean that
gets a light yeah it's it's not it's not
about like I want to [__] that it's just
more like I it's not what you do yeah if
you if you're like a red car driving by
you're just like whoa what the [__] was
that say say if Nina had a sister and
she was at your place and she was doing
that and she was scantily clad right I
know and then she she was walking around
and then you you catch for a second you
just gotta be like
yeah I'm literally turning around I'm
going the other way yeah you gotta dude
you gotta leave yeah I'm I'm driving
away [__] put some clothes on like I
think that's not unreasonable or same
thing if I'm in my boxes and then it's
like a family member's over I'm like and
I'm gonna oh [__] I'm going back
upstairs I'm putting on pants like you
know what I mean there's no what if
they're like this and then you're just
like oh we're all comfortable here
and then they're just like oh that's
weird I'm like Hey Joe can you come over
do the jacking off thing yeah
that's when you need Joe for sure
because then I I'll be like oh two can
play this uncomfortable game he's not
uncomfortable at all playing that game
yeah
foreign